Hi, I'm Tom from the Burp Scanner development team. Today I'd like to talk a little bit about
paths in Burp Scanner. We talk about paths a lot on the team as being what our scanner really finds
when it crawls and what makes it so powerful. So what do we mean by that? Here I've got a post
request that can be found in Portswigger's Gin and Juice shop that contains a single-use
CSERF token. If I go ahead and try to repeat this request with the same CSERF token, it's not going
to work. If the scanner did this when it was sending payloads, it would have the same result
and we wouldn't find our issue. What Burp Scanner does instead is it finds the shortest path through
an application to a request so that when that request is issued, we get a consistent response.
To demonstrate that, I've got a scan set up here and ready to go, crawling and auditing from the
page where this post request form is found. I've set up some scope rules in CrawlerConfig just to
stop the Crawler from going too far past the request you're interested in just for the sake of
reducing noise. And I've only enabled an issue I know to be present. So if we go ahead and open
this task and head to the logger and we start to scroll down to where payloads are being sent, we can
see that Burp Scanner has identified that the shortest path through the application to this request so that
when we reissue it we get a correct CSERF token is to first go to the product page and then submit the form.
And we can see that the CSERF token has been updated and we're getting a correct response.
We're currently exploring ways to better surface these paths visually in Burp Suite so that's
something to look out for soon.
If that makes sense.